"Roll On" is back in style resplendent.
Adam, here's where I ask you that question.
What's that?
Should we do the show?
Today, I think we should.
I think we should too, let's do it.
♪ Born in 1966 ♪
♪ He turned his life around ♪
♪ Wasn't doing so hot ♪
♪ Rich Roll ♪
♪ He got rid of that weight and he gained a lot of wisdom ♪
♪ He lives in a tent ♪
♪ Rich Roll ♪
Thank you all so much for playing along
and I hope you have a wonderful night
and I'd like to welcome to the stage Mr. Rich Roll.
Hey everybody, welcome to "Roll On"
where my journalist appendage, Mr. Adam Skolnick and I,
rip matters of interest from the headlines
and our lived experience.
We riff on sports, culture, entertainment, self betterment,
we answer a few listener questions and so much more.
Today, we've got a fun, I should say light in comparison
to at least the "Roll On" from two weeks ago,
show today, we're gonna announce the winners
of the 2021 Rollies, very exciting,
talk a little bit of endurance news,
answer one single listener question.
And once again, we're gonna close
with a coaching call check in with friend of the pod,
my coach, Chris Hauth,
the man guiding me towards this perhaps ill faded
12 and a half mile open water swim race
that is looming on my calendar, but first,
how goes it, comrade?
Rich, Larry Ellison owes me $25.
That sounds like a story.
It's not that great of a story, but I went,
with the family and I, we went to the tennis tournament,
Larry's tennis tournament, Indian Wells.
And we had two days planned, one day we took my parents,
we got like two stadium seats and we had two grounds passes
and we brought Zuma, 'cause April was a very high ranked
junior tennis player in Australia
so tennis is a big deal in our house.
So anyway, we parked the car in this huge grassy lot
looks like the size of Coachella festival
and as we're walking, we're pushing the stroller,
it's a vaccinated only entrance thing
and Zuma is under five, can't be vaxxed
but usually they're allowed in anyway.
But in this case,
we had all the people who were working in the parking lot
saying, they're not gonna let him in,
they're not gonna let him in, so we were prepared.
So I go up to the counter or whatever the ticket place
to get my refund because I said,
"Well okay, I'll just get my money back",
couldn't go because they wouldn't let Zuma in
and no where on the website does it say
under five aren't allowed.
And so then, but she wouldn't give me
my parking refund (chuckles)
because she couldn't, it's been scanned.
Yeah.
So like, they is no way for her to do it.
And so I'm like okay, and she said
"You can just email this guy and he'll--
Larry Ellison directly?
And it turned out to be Larry
(Rich chuckles)
I haven't heard back yet.
Okay.
Yeah.
So how are we gonna get justice for you for this?
You know, Larry's very busy.
I don't wanna be an apologist for Larry, he is very busy.
He does owe me $25 and I am gonna tax
some interest on there.
Well maybe when you're out swimming,
you'll see him fly by on one of his sailboats.
Yeah, well to make matters worse, I shorted Twitter.
Yeah, not smart.
Yeah because Elon--
But who knows.
Elon comes in, he's a regular at the B & J
and he (Adam chuckles)
Ben and Jerry's, okay.
Yeah, he comes in, he gets a--
Make sure that won't die.
He gets a triple scoop, I'm just saying.
And he told me he was gonna buy Twitter,
he was gonna bull rush Twitter.
And I thought he was kidding, 'cause he's that kind of guy.
We have a--
That's your rapport.
Like you and I.
Right.
You know, we have a thing (Adam chuckles)
and I thought he was fucking with me, so I shorted Twitter.
(Rich chuckles)
It's gonna be interesting to see what pans out with that.
I know.
It's all upside down.
Poison pill and everything.
That's a different podcast though,
we're not gonna pick that one apart today, I don't.
We're not getting into Elon's head today.
I will say that I stood behind Larry Ellison,
in line at CVS once.
(both chuckle)
How did that go?
I don't know.
I mean, it was just, he was buying band aids or something
I can't even remember, this was years ago.
Celebrities are just like us--
What's interesting is that, you know,
he owns like an insane amount of Malibu beachfront property,
including I think where like Nobu and the Soho Houses
and that--
Doesn't he own the Maru and the Rio?
I think so, I think so, yeah.
Yeah and Lanai, he owns the island.
I know he owns like that whole island, right?
Yeah.
Founder of Oracle for people that don't know.
Which is cloud stuff--
He did make an appearance in founder television.
Did you watch the "Dropout?"
I watched the first cause we were talking,
I watched the first episode of the drama.
Yeah, yeah, so he is portrayed in that many series.
Including a scene with Elizabeth Holmes
played by Amanda Seyfried on one of his yachts
in the San Francisco.
He does seem to live well.
(chuckles) Yeah, anyway, that is all side
of what we're actually gonna talk about today.
Yes.
But first I should probably check in what's going.
Yeah what's going on with you?
I know you were in Miami.
Adam I'm always waiting, you know, I always ask you,
what's going on with you,
you never ask me what's going on with me.
It's true (chuckles)
I feel unfulfilled in this relationship--
I miss my cue (chuckles)
Every week I miss my cue.
You know--
What's going on with you?
If we're gonna have a healthy relationship,
it has to be two ways.
That's what I told Elon yesterday.
Okay anyway, I'm good.
I was in Miami like two weeks ago
and had this incredible experience,
I hosted my first conference.
Yeah.
It was for this organization called YPO,
Young President's Organization.
I've done a lot of events for this organization
over the years and--
What does that mean?
It's basically like this global organization of young CEOS
and each kind of local chapter functions,
almost like a mastermind group
where it it's pretty cool though.
Like they really help each other out
and they have all these like family,
community oriented events and all this infrastructure,
but it's essentially like young CEOs,
I think there's a cap on the age limit.
Okay.
And it's, you know, kind of like a way for them to,
you know, have a means to, you know,
share what's going on with them
and have other people help out, et cetera, et cetera.
Info share, mentorship.
And they do like a lot of speaking stuff.
So like when I went to Pakistan and Saudi Arabia and Bahrain
and Morocco, like all of those were YPO events.
Okay.
Which is cool, but I--
Do they cap on the boomers when they're in private?
Yeah, I don't know.
But this was my first stab at actually hosting
like an all day event.
Interest.
Where I had to be on stage, like I don't know,
14 times over the course of the day.
And it was a wellness oriented thing,
where a lot of friends of the podcast
were actually the speakers,
like Matthew Walker and Valter Longo,
Leah Gabby were there, Dan Buettner,
Mark Hyman was there,
Ken Cook from the Environmental Working Group,
Chip Conley, who's this hotelier
who was instrumental in helping build Airbnb,
who now has this thing called the Modern Elder Academy,
he was super cool.
Cool.
Ken and Chip, I'm definitely getting on the podcast,
we're trying to schedule all that right now.
But my point being like, I thought it would be like,
oh, it'll be cool,
like you just get up and you introduce each guest,
like how hard can it be?
Right.
And then when I got into like the responsibility
of what that entailed, because you're basically like
charged with holding the energy of the crowd
and keeping this thing moving.
Right.
And having, you know,
making sure that everyone's really engaged
and interested in what's happening
and ended up like rehearsing for like eight hours
the day before, wrote like a 35 page script.
And then during the day was like revising the script
and trying to find jokes
and you know, it was a cool challenge
and definitely like a puzzle
that I've never tried to assemble before,
but it was pretty thrilling.
It went well?
Yeah I dug it, it was super fun.
And everyone was into it?
Yeah, I think so.
I mean, I think it went really well
and I found like a groove with it.
I found it to be more fulfilling
than just being one of the keynote people.
Right.
'Cause it's like, okay, it's up to you.
Like, can you get these people excited?
Can you make sure that they're holding their attention?
Can you keep them entertained?
Can you keep this thing moving on time,
all that kind of stuff.
Right.
Like it was pretty cool.
So anyway, that was really gratifying.
Cool.
I really wanna do more of that,
like that kind of busted my cherry with that type of work.
And I have such a whole new level of respect
for people that host, 'cause I think it's easy to look at,
you know, I don't know people that host
like reality TV shows and the like,
and just be like, you know, they just read, you know,
they're reading off teleprompter, how hard can it be?
Like "The Bachelor" guy?
Yeah, like, well I called my friend Osher Günsberg
who hosts "The Bachelor" in Australia
and I was like, 'cause I was having a panic moment.
I was like, dude, I gotta do this thing tomorrow.
And I just realized like it's so much more intense
than I thought it would be.
Right.
And I only have so much time to get ready,
like you gotta talk me through this.
And he spent a couple hours with me on the phone
and it was incredibly helpful.
He gave me all of these tips and tools
'cause he's been doing it for like 25 years.
I like the "Amazing Race" guy, Jeff Probst.
Yeah, right.
I could see you as a Jeff Probst.
I mean, it's a cool thing.
Like I was very dismissive of the whole thing
until I did it and I was like, wow, this is like a lot,
you know?
Right, yeah no.
Props to anybody who hosts stuff.
Yeah.
So that was very cool.
And I had gone to Miami a couple days earlier
so I could get some swimming in and prep for this race.
Got a bunch of cool open water swims under my belt,
including one, the final day,
I shared this on social media and I talked to you about it.
Right.
I was out, I was probably a little bit too offshore,
like Miami beach, it stays pretty shallow
until you get pretty far out.
And it was a little bit choppier than I would've liked,
so I wanted to get past the break, but it was still only,
I was probably like 200 meters offshore.
Okay.
It was still only like maybe eight feet deep.
Right.
So it's not like, oh man,
I'm out at open sea or anything like that,
it's all very manageable swimming along.
And then four, five foot lemon sharks swam just beneath me,
like right along the bottom.
Yeah.
Which was super cool.
But also, you know, it's like, dude, they're sharks.
They're right there.
You sharks look like sharks.
(both chuckle)
And I know that lemon sharks are not the most aggressive.
And I found myself much calmer in the situation
that I would've predicted.
I was like, okay,
I should probably get a little bit closer to shore
and kind of calmly pivoted towards shore.
And it's not like any of them even noticed me
or anything like that.
Well, they probably noticed you, but they didn't care.
Right but they don't give a shit.
Right.
Right, which is that's--
And they used go close to shore too,
I mean that's that 200,
it's not like they're staying at 200.
Do you know much about lemon sharks?
No, would you like me to Google?
Well live right now.
Live Google.
Yeah, I mean my understanding,
I mean, they're not innocuous,
like they have attacked people.
I don't think I don't they've ever killed,
I don't know if they've ever killed anybody.
It's so rare for people to get even bite, it's crazy rare.
You know, it's insane.
But they weren't small.
I mean, they were like the length of this table.
No they can get 11 feet, they can get...
Those are probably juveniles, they can I'm just looking--
And they look like, you know,
it's not like they look different
than what you would expect.
Sharks always look so Sharky don't they.
(both chuckle)
They can be counted on for that.
The funky kinda like port--
We just found the title of this podcast.
Sharks can look so sharky.
I mean, leopard sharks--
That's the quote graphic that we're gonna uses.
Like nurse sharks have the little like catfish thing
of that makes you realize the whale sharks
still look Sharky,
but they, you know, they don't bite you,
but everything from reef shark up looks so Sharky.
Let's see what it says, what does it eat?
It eats--
Human fingers.
Known ultra athletes that wrote books.
Exactly (chuckles)
That's a very small group of people.
Loves podcasters, yeah they eat crustaceans.
You know, they're not eating, they're not eating humans.
No, I know.
So that was a cool experience,
I'd never been out in the water and seen a shark
in the wild.
Never?
No.
What about in Hawaii?
You never seen it, never seen reef sharks?
Dolphins, but never no, really,
maybe tiny little sharks that I don't even remember,
but nothing that was like, wow, that's a legit.
A legit shark.
Group of sharks right there.
Yeah, yeah.
You know, that's fun.
In any event, the conference that I was at
was just prior to the Bitcoin conference.
Okay.
Which is what brings like, that was like a big deal.
So I left like the day before that started,
but I have a bunch of friends that are Bitcoiners,
who came into town early.
So I was able to see one or two of them.
And did you guys hit the clubs?
It made me...
No, like, but I have this friend, Peter McCormack.
Yeah.
Who has the biggest Bitcoin podcast
it's called "What Bitcoin Did"
And he came on one of our retreats to Italy
several years ago.
And he had this idea of starting a Bitcoin podcast
and I kind of helped him get it up on his feet.
And now he's like the man in Bitcoin,
like he ended up like hosting essentially
like a full day of the conference,
like he's a big name in that world.
And it made me think like, oh,
maybe Peter would be a good guest,
like I've never had anyone on to talk about Bitcoin.
Yeah, that's a good idea, yeah.
I have a lot to--
We've attempted to talk about NFT.
Yeah, I'm the furthest thing from an expert on crypto.
No.
But any going away and that Bitcoin conference
was a big deal.
You know what, my favorite thing about crypto is
the Larry David commercial.
That you don't have any of it?
No, the Larry David...
I do have some.
Oh, is that the super bowl commercial one?
Yeah, yeah.
I can't remember whether I saw that or not.
Oh yeah it's great. Well, will link it in the show notes.
There's a long form on YouTube.
I yeah, no, I do own some Bitcoin, not Bitcoin,
some lesser known cryptos (chuckles)
Some weird crypto coin.
(Adam chuckles)
All right, why is that?
No, I own some lesser known cryptos.
I own a tin y bit of (garbled speech).
Quite taken off yet.
I own like a negligible amount of Bitcoin,
Like a quarter of a coin?
Oh, less than that.
A quarter of a coin would be,
I mean, Bitcoin's at 40 grand right now.
Okay, I think--
So a quarter of a coin would be.
10 full grand.
Yeah, it would be 10 grand.
Okay.
I don't have that.
Larry Ellison, if you're listening,
you can put that 25 straight into a Bitcoin.
Right?
Percentage.
With your Bitcoin wallet, your crypto wallet.
In my crypto wallet.
Exactly.
Not yours, Larry.
But here's the thing I returned from Florida with COVID.
(both chuckle)
Which is interesting because I thought COVID
didn't exist in Florida,
but maybe that's why I didn't start to experience symptoms
until I was on the plane home.
I like that joke. But Rich, I think it's good,
you left Miami with a communicative disease,
like you should have.
(both chuckle)
Right?
I mean, I interacted with hundreds of people.
Yeah.
It was spring break, the Bitcoiners were coming into town.
Wait. you also spring break?
Well like you're in these hotels at Miami beach.
And it's just like
like at the pools all day long and all night,
you can't escape it.
And the music let's, you know what?
I like dance music, I like house music.
This is where I'm an old man.
Listen, I like dancing.
Does anybody like this music?
I like the disco house, the old stuff.
This crap, this like Miami version, it's remarkable.
Well, what's interesting is that in Miami
everywhere you go, that's the soundtrack.
(Adam chuckles)
I went to the Time Out Food Court,
like Time Out builds these food courts all over the world
with like, and they're pretty cool spaces.
And they had built one on Lincoln Road in Miami
and I had never seen it or been to it.
I was like, oh, I'm gonna go check it out
and I walked in and it was like, like so loud in there.
Right.
That I did a loop and just walked out,
I was like, I can't, I can't eat in here.
Oh, that was the dinner soundtrack.
No, it was in the middle of the day.
What let me hear what was the soundtrack again?
It's just like
(Adam chuckles)
You know, like, come on all right, anyway.
Wait (chuckles)
Wait, what hotel did you stay in?
I was at the W.
Is The Standard still there, 'cause they closed here?
The Standard was there, but the Delano,
which was kind of like the OG hotspot,
is closed down right now.
And that used to be the furthest north than anybody would go
in south beach before it kind of got gnarly,
now it goes quite a bit further north,
but there's still, you know,
it's like, it's an interesting spot, like.
I like Miami.
I do too.
I think Miami has some charms.
Some people don't like it,
'cause it looks like shallow on the surface.
I like that it's like this great Pan-American city,
probably the only Pan-American city
where people from all over Latin America live,
it's a true bilingual city.
It's got great Cuban and just Latino food in general,
Mexican Cuban, whatever everything's there.
Yeah and if you're there and you wanna eat plant-based
you gotta go to Love Life.
Okay.
In Wynwood.
So our friends, Diego and Veronica own this restaurant,
their geniuses, it is the best plant-based restaurant
I've ever been.
Really.
And that's like, I say that, like I've been to a lot of--
Wow, you're gonna get a lot of phone calls and text.
I know, i love it, they're so good.
Diego's recipes are incredible.
Does he have a cookbook?
I love it, I shared it...
No, they don't have a cookbook.
I think one of the recipes is gonna be in,
in Dan Buettner's next book.
Okay.
Which is coming out soon.
Oh cool.
And they're making some cool moves`,
that aren't public yet, but I'll be sharing about soon.
Buettner's living out--
I love them, so yeah that's my recommendation.
Love Life in Wynwood.
Good stuff.
But anyway, yeah I came back with COVID.
That's why there was no "Roll On" last week.
Right.
Which is, you know, we would've typically done it then.
How was it for you?
It was pretty mild, you know, I was vaccinated.
So within a couple days I was kind of over it,
I didn't lose my taste, I didn't lose my smell.
I had two nights where I experienced
some form of fever and chills.
So for 48 hours just at night, I got like, you know,
shivery or whatever.
And then basically just kind of achy and weak
for a couple days and then it passed, so--
Did you isolate somewhere in the house?
I isolated in my tent.
You stayed in the tent?
So I was like the English patient.
You were, it was like, you were--
Tyler was joking.
The small pocks guy (chuckle)
Like it's 1910 and you're recovering from consumption.
Yes (chuckles)
No isolation in the tent in the backyard.
That's really funny.
The only problem is it was like 95 degrees out,
so the tent got way too hot in the middle of the day
for me to convalesce.
Right.
But yeah, I isolated and everybody else
in the family is fine.
I basically just hydrated, slept, rested.
I did do a five day course of PAXLOVID,
which is an antiviral that was recommended to me.
And I think that probably expedited
how quickly I got over it.
In addition to that, I took a lot of supplements.
I took about 40,000 IUD of vitamin D every day,
vitamin C, vitamin K, Cocuten, Curcumin on top of
what I typically take,
which is just a multivitamin athletic greens,
B 12 and stuff like that, so--
So your pee was like rainbow color.
It was very, yeah, it was very yellow, it was very yellow.
But three and a half day days in, I was pretty much fine.
I had talked to a bunch of athletes who were cautioning me
not to get back into any kind of training
and to really take my time with it
because it can snap back on you.
Right.
I've had friends that have taken three weeks off,
but I felt like five days in,
I was like, I felt completely fine.
So I went back to the pool at on day six,
I think for a light swim.
And I've just been slowly building since then,
but I feel a hundred percent now.
Nice.
But I did miss, I think seven days of training.
So in the context of training for this, you know,
long open water swim,
that is not too far away in the future
that you know, definitely set me back.
Seems like you're rocking it though
from Instagram stories.
Okay, it's been nice to just be in the pool
and focus on swimming every day,
'cause during all of the ultra endurance races
that I trained for,
I would only swim two or three days a week
because the focus was on other stuff.
So it's been decades since I just focused on swimming
and kind of swim pretty much every day and it feels good.
I feel strong and getting stronger every day.
You look great.
Thank you, sir.
Yeah.
Thank you.
What else we got a quick little of housekeeping
before we move into the next thing?
Matthew Walker, who was in Miami,
I talked to him about coming back on the podcast.
Oh cool.
And I think what we wanna do is
an AMA formatted conversation,
that's obviously specific to sleep.
We haven't scheduled it yet,
but we'll be doing that at some point in the spring
or the summer.
And I thought it would be good
to just make the announcement now,
if you have a sleep question,
you can submit that on our voicemail at
424-235-4626,
or you can send an email to our rrpstudio@richroll.com,
so sleep questions only to that email from Matthew Walker.
We'll go through all the questions of course,
find the best one and kind of do
a very structured sleep oriented conversation.
I'm really not that great at sleep,
if Matthew cares to tinker with me in any way.
I think Matthew cares deeply Adam.
Yeah, he seems like a caring guy.
He is, he's a wonderful, wonderful man.
Yeah.
All right, well let's do our endurance sport check in,
we got a lot of (garbled speech)
I know let's do it.
Where do you wanna start?
Robbie Balenger.
Of course.
He's John Henry or as I call John Henry 2.0
or as I call him Don Juan Henry.
Don Juan, yeah he is very charming with that mustache.
(Adam chuckles) Very swarthy.
Don Juan Henry.
The idea was that he was going to outlast a Tesla.
I think there's a lot of people who don't know--
Tesla, you pronounce it Tesla.
As opposed to what?
Tesla.
Tesla, Tesla, Tesla, like a Z with a Z vibe on it.
That's what you said.
I don't know,
I'm not even consciously aware of how pronouncing it.
My point though, is that you throw the name, John Henry out,
like everybody know who that is.
People don't who John Henry is.
Do they not learn that in grade school?
There might be a lot of people out there
who are less studied in American history.
So spell it out.
John Henry, it was this period of time when
basically people were building the roads
and getting through mountains.
So they would blow it up and then people would kind of go in
with a pick ax and like hack their way through mountains.
And then the steam engine was invented,
and John Henry was the greatest of them all.
He was the guy that he did the work of 20 men,
there's like folk songs about him.
Yeah, he was like the David Goggins of road engineers.
(chuckles) He was the workhorse beyond like,
he was like, you know, 50 men, he ate like, you know,
10 steaks for breakfast kind of thing, I forget what it was.
And he was like revered.
And this steam engine came along
and promised to put him all outta work.
And so John Henry was challenged to beat the steam engine,
I think he did it for his fellow workers.
You know, let's show this engine whose boss
and the coal powered steam engine versus John Henry
and John Henry was in a race, but it was a timed race.
And John Henry beats the steam engine
and then dies on the spot.
Basically like drilling through, the side of a mountain.
Right and then he dies at the finish line.
Right.
But he wins, there's a great book
called "John Henry Days" by Colson Whitehead,
who I've name dropped on this podcast a few times before.
It's one of his first books,
I think it's his second or third.
Very, very, very funny, very poignant, it's excellent.
And so "John Henry Days"
and I actually recommended that to Robbie
in case he was interested.
Right, well not to spoil it, Robbie did not die
at the end of his challenge.
And it wasn't timed.
It wasn't timed and he did technically outlast the Tesla,
although he didn't meet his kind of time goal.
Yeah.
So basically this Tesla starts out
on the outskirts of Austin and drives until
it has a full battery charge
and drives until the battery dies.
It goes 242 miles
and Robbie's challenge was to run that distance
from where the Tesla started in under 72 hours.
He succeeded in (clears throat) running the full 242 miles,
it took him a little bit longer just under 77 hours.
And I think, you know, the heat and humidity
of the Texas Hill Country--
Crazy.
Like an average of 93 degrees Fahrenheit,
plus 13,000 feet of elevation gain.
We think of Texas as flat,
but they did it in the hill country.
So lots of ups and downs, was you know,
it laid the pain on him.
It's a lot of miles.
And I had serious FOMO watching this
'cause I was invited to attend and support
and I really wanted to,
but I had just gotten back from Miami
and didn't feel like I could leave town again.
Plus I had COVID so I couldn't have gone,
even if I had agreed to do it.
So I just watched it on Instagram, like everybody else.
But what was cool as so many cool people
and friends of the podcast were there to support Robbie.
We had Hellah was there Hellah Sidibe , of course,
Dan Churchill, who hasn't been on the podcast,
but is a good friend of mine.
He is the owner and head chef at Charlie Street
in New York city.
Just an amazing dude,
a guy that everybody should follow on Instagram,
he shares recipes and training stuff,
super positive fit dude, Australian,
contributor to Chris Hemsworth Centr app.
Oh really?
I love this guy and he's an incredible athlete as well.
So I pulled up his...
Blake, you can pull up his, there it is.
There's his page, so Dan_Churchill.
He's very photogenic.
He's very handsome and charming.
Yeah.
And positive.
Must be nice.
Wonderful, wonderful guy.
Robbie of course is Robbie Balenger on Instagram,
there's his page you can watch him on YouTube.
So he was sharing of course, you know,
images and videos along the way,
but here's the idea basically, outlast of Tesla.
And he did.
He did it, we had Hellah there as well.
Here's Hellah with another guy who showed up
to support Robbie.
William Goodge.
Goodge.
Goodge, who Robbie supported
when William ran the circumference of the...
I think he ran around the Unite Kingdom.
Yeah.
Like a year ago and Robbie went out
to crew for him and support him.
He's an incredible athlete, very unique human being.
He ran like 48 marathons in 30 days.
Crazy.
And then in the week, like prior to Robbie's challenge,
he did Marathon des Sables,
and he shared all his WHOOP scores.
Like I think WHOOP posted a bunch of stuff
like on their website, maybe I can find a link to that.
And then like a day later he went to Zurich
and ran a marathon there.
And then he flew to Austin did the Robbie thing
and then he went like straight to Coachella.
(Adam chuckles)
Now he is like a hype beast in Coachella.
Like this guy, like he wears gold chains,
he's very like, he's like a hype beast.
And there's something like kind of cool (Adam chuckles)
I like that the baggy sweats are back.
I noticed his clothes are baggy.
I mean he's a style master this dude, like,
you know, check him out.
But like a beast of an athlete
and it was cool that Robbie supported him
and then he flew all the way, you know,
basically halfway around the world to support Robbie.
Here's William at MBS.
Oh, nice.
Looking like a fashion model, out on the sand.
Anyway, really cool.
Congrats to Robbie for his latest adventure, that was a--
You mean Don Juan Henry.
Don Juan Henry, support worded by 10,000 of course
that works with Dan Churchill and I.
Yes.
Among another, you know, a group of really cool athletes.
So it was kind of a 10,000 sponsored challenge.
It was.
Yeah.
It was cool to watch.
It will be cool to see what Robbie does next.
(garbled speech)
At one point, it looked like he was real shaky.
Like he could move if he was moving, he was fine.
But like getting up from his support vehicle
and getting back on his feet, man,
there were times where he was like--
Wobbly.
He was real wobbly, yeah.
Yeah, super wobbly.
And then he was running like, no problem.
And then he was fine, yeah.
And that's the way these ultras are.
You look like, oh, this guy's done.
You know, there's no way you can't even walk.
And then a couple hours later or nightfall
gets a little bit cooler out,
gets some calories and some food, a little bit of a nap.
And then all of a sudden it's a new human.
Amazing Congrats.
Good on you, Robbie.
Sorry, I wasn't there to support you, we love you though.
And it's cool to see you continue
to inspire people all over the world.
A hundred percent.
But Robbie plays a big part in the next dispatch
from the world of endurance
that we're gonna talk about today.
Yes, you mean Oz's central park loop record.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The Oz Pearlman record, yeah.
You know, if you have not seen, I mean,
I feel like you're listeners and our listeners,
our listeners, I feel like our--
Own it Adam.
Our listeners are aware of what happened.
You were Instagramming about it, tweeting about it.
Oz Pearlman, Oz the mentalist
who is just recently a guest on this here program
wanted to set the record for the FKT
for most loops around central park.
He ended up doing 19 loops, 116 miles--
In a day.
And it's important to note that--
It's 18 Hours, 50 minutes.
Yeah, it's only the part that loop is only open
during certain hours of that, like 6:00 AM to 1:00 AM
or something like.
Right, that's right. 6:00 AM.
And you can't start till 6:05
and you have to finish at 12:55.
So he gives you 18:50 when,
and he's breaking Robbie's record.
Robbie did 16 loops and Robbie held the second FKT
so it's not that like it's been around a long time.
It started in 2020 someone laid down,
I believe it was 12 loops it's in the article.
Aaron Zellhoefer I believe is his name.
And by the article you must be referring
to the New York Times article that you wrote.
Yes, so I was lucky enough to be able to cover it.
So I knew Oz was gonna go for this.
Oz, you know, the backstory of the whole article
is that David Goggins invited me to a zoom
at the beginning of the pandemic
when Oz was like having to transition his business
from live shows to zoom.
And I'd heard of Oz before, but I hadn't really, you know,
I wasn't really that acquainted with how great he was.
And I sat in on this zoom
and I saw him predict like the serial numbers
on some dollar bill and some dude's wallet,
like 2000 miles away from him through zoom
and I realized, wow, this guy's amazing.
And then quickly after that,
I found out he was a great runner.
And so I stayed in contact with him,
just mostly Instagram messaging.
And then I, you know,
said if there's ever an event he's gonna tackle,
let me know, 'cause I think it be a cool story.
And he was going to do last summer,
Mon talked to Manhattan 170 miles,
but it didn't end up happening.
And so I'd already gotten New York Times sports
interested in that.
And then he called me like two weeks before this,
so three weeks ago now, two weeks before this
and said what do you think of me doing this?
And I said, I think that's great.
And so I talked to my editor,
who's in charge of endurance and adventure sports
at New York Times, her name's Talya Minsberg.
And we talked about Oz and she quickly got on board.
And so I did it, you know, at first I said,
you're the New York Times in Central Park.
Like, I can't get there and you don't need me there,
you have a whole office of reporters, really good ones,
why don't you just do it?
I wasn't even gonna do it.
And or that's how I positioned it,
but it turns out she wanted me to do it,
so I ended up having to report it remotely.
But Hilary Swift, who did amazing photographs,
she was also kind of my eyes and ears,
so we stayed in contact,
I was obviously watching him on Instagram.
I Face Timed with him, I called him, I texted everything.
So I had full access,
but it was interesting that it was a remote story.
And you talked to Robbie also.
I talked to Robbie forehand,
so I interviewed Oz and Robbie the week before.
And so that was cool,
it was my first chance to really talk to Robbie
and understand what he's about.
So he's mentioned in there,
the best story that's not in there,
is there's a guy named George Hirsch,
should we heard of George Hirsch?
He's the chairman of the New York Road Runners,
he's like 87 years old, I believe.
And he also is a giant in publishing,
he started New York Magazine.
He went on to become the first global editor
of men's health.
Wow.
And so head of head of men's health,
started New York Magazine, also a giant in running,
not is he now the acting chairman of New York Road Runners,
he is the founder of the five-borough New York City Marathon
Wow.
So he changed that whole course
and was an early runner like in the sixties,
he's running around, nobody's running.
Anyway so he became friends with Oz many years ago
and so he knew about, you know,
he's known him for a long time.
And at one point when his wife was in the hospital,
she died of cancer.
And when she was in the hospital,
after like a treatment went bad,
Oz was out on a long run and stop by
and he could tell he was running
stopped by to lift her spirits,
'cause they'd had dinner, they were close.
And he comes in and says to his way,
you know, he does a whole thing with his wife
to lift her spirits.
And at one point he's like, this is what George described,
he says, "I want you to think of one person
that is famous and one person who's not."
And she said, "okay."
And then he goes over to her laptop
and he pulls up a picture of Bill Clinton
and turns it to her.
And she's like of course, wow you know, it's crazy.
And then I wanna get this right,
so I'm gonna go to, then he scribbles down a note to,
you know, and hands it to her.
And she opens up the note
and let me just make sure I get it.
And she opens up the note and it says,
say hello to Shirley.
And George's wife was named Shea,
that's Shea's childhood best friend from Idaho, Shirley.
And so like, that's the kind of stuff he's doing
and the fact that took his time out and he did that.
I think that's amazing.
And I really wanted George to be part of the story,
but there just wasn't enough words.
And so they ended up using an example of what he did to me,
which at mile 80.
Right.
Which was--
You're on the phone with him.
Yeah.
He's on mile 80.
Mile, 80.
He's like running while talking to you on the phone.
FaceTime.
And he's like, Adam, I want you to think of a friend.
And I said, okay.
And he goes, he said, no you're not thinking
if his your friend I could find, I could have researched.
You're thinking less clearly than me and I'm at mile 80.
I want you to think of your first crush.
And so I said, okay, I thought of my first crush.
Then he asked me, you know,
how many letters were in her name or think,
yeah, no, he said, think of her name,
then he didn't ask me how many letters
he said, "I want you to count the letters in her name."
I said, okay done and he goes,
see now I know it's a short name.
Short name.
Yeah, he got that right away, but that still doesn't...
I mean, it was an odd name
and so then, you know, pretty quickly he gets it.
It's ROZ, R-O-Z.
It's really remarkable how quickly he gets it.
And this is someone I haven't talked to,
I haven't heard from,
I haven't had any contact with in decades.
So there's impossible for him to like, it's just incredible.
And he's run 80 miles miles at this point.
I mean, he did that time and time again,
we just put up a video of kind of behind the scenes
of when he was here, where he's screwing around
with the team here and doing all kinds of shenanigans
and it's just, it's unbelievable.
Yeah, Blake, who the hell is Iman?
So that was the version of what he did
to Harshe's wife, right?
Like he basically pulls this name out of nowhere.
Yeah.
So quickly.
So he's a magical man.
It is wizardry.
Yeah, it's really awesome.
And it was a lot of fun to write it and it was cool.
It was one of those stories I'll remember.
So if you're watching on YouTube,
we're just kind of sharing the New York Times article
and in print, it was beautiful.
I mean, they put all of these photographs in there
and it was a full page deal, so that's gotta be cool.
Yeah, it was cool.
And yeah, it was--
And how does it work with the New York Times?
It tease to A1.
Oh, to yeah Tease day one, right?
That's a big deal.
Yeah.
Like, so you submit,
you get like the green light to write this thing.
Right.
They assign a photographer, even though you're not there,
you do your reporting, you write the thing,
you turn it in and then goes through like a fact checking
and an editorial process, right
and they strip a bunch of stuff out of it.
I mean, I think it depends on the desk.
With sports stuff, I do my own fact checking,
I want it real tight.
So what happens is I report it, I'll file it
and then depending on the quick turnaround,
this one, we published Monday,
so there wasn't like, they had stuff already Saturday
and Sunday covered, so they didn't need more stories.
And so we were later than everybody else,
which means you have to be better than everybody else,
you have to be smarter, right.
So but we also had more space.
So I file it and then Talya does an edit,
gets it back to me, I might make some changes,
then there's a second edit, like a copy, edit top,
edit in that period of time, I'm doing all my fact checking.
And then I...
So anything, I'm not a hundred percent certain on,
I will call whoever.
So with Oz I had to call him like three times on Monday.
And then he here's the other thing.
So we didn't even say what he did,
he did 19 loops, 116 miles.
Right.
Crushes the record.
Yap.
Goes home, it's you know, at that point it's like,
what two in the morning or something like that,
goes home grabs a couple hours of sleep
and then has a 1:00 PM flight to Augusta
'cause he's doing a show at the master.
Yes.
The next day.
Totally fine, he's fine.
And then he shares this and he is like,
I feel guilty for not running today,
or I feel like I need to go running.
He only lost one toe nail.
'Cause he's on a streak, I think too.
Yeah, well, no, he took a week off.
Oh, he did.
Took a week off.
Okay.
Shout out Hillary Swift, the photographer.
She was on a bicycle like riding around with him all day,
she must have done 50 miles on the bicycle
and she's a good marathoner, she's a sub four hour marathon.
Friends with Alexi Pappas--
And friends with Alexi Pappas
and Talya the editor on this was also just ran Boston today.
And she's a sub four hour marathoner.
So we're gonna talk about Boston,
but let's take a quick break and we'll be right back.
Prophets walk among us,
as a writer and podcaster for nearly 10 years,
I've become more convinced than ever
that our world is populated by scores of beautiful
and brilliant people who have amazing stories to share,
those that we don't know who can teach us something new
and leave us all the better
for the experience of their sharing.
And so I've dedicated my career to tracking down
the most compelling prophets on the planet,
going deep with each of them on my podcast,
to elucidate the best of what they have to offer
and to sharing the insights gleaned for the benefit of all.
But the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their story,
which is why I'm proud to announce
the release of my new book, "Voicing Change Volume Two."
More than mere words on paper,
"Voicing Change" is a physical manifestation of the magic,
inspiration and timeless wisdom that transpires each week
on the "Rich Roll Podcast."
The first edition of "Voicing Change"
was a beautifully rendered book
worthy of display on any coffee table
and volume two follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite conversations
in an elegant publication replete with interview excerpts,
essays, and stunning photography
making for an exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying standalone work.
Picking up this book allows you to
revisit the wisdom of your favorite everyday prophets
and physically interact with the life changing ideas
contained with it.
"Voicing Change Volume Two"
available now while supplies last for a limited time.
Order your copy today only@richroll.com.
All right and we're back,
we're gonna talk about Boston for a couple minutes.
Today is Monday, so Boston was just run
and concluded right before we started recording.
By the time anybody listens to this,
it will be Thursday at a minimum.
So there'll be lots of articles out
and hot takes, et cetera.
So I don't wanna spend a ton of time on this
other than to just kind of note
a couple interesting performances.
First of all, friend of the pod, Scott Fauble
been on the show for previous amazing Boston experience.
He came in as the fastest American in seventh,
ran PR of 2:08:52, seventh fastest American of all time.
And what's interesting is that he's unsponsored right now.
Really?
So he literally wore a Lulu lemon tank top
that he bought himself off the rack.
Incredible.
Which is crazy.
Yeah.
Right.
He's gonna be sponsored now.
And interestingly, he even split the race.
He went from 22nd to seventh in the second half,
ran 64, 26 for the first half
and 64, 26 for the second half, which is unbelievable.
Fastest American man, since med in 2014.
So a burrito for you sir, that's his thing burrito,
we love you, Scott congratulations.
They were a lot of eyes on this athlete, CJ Albertson.
He ended up being the third American runner 2:10, his PR
and the reason there's a lot of eyes on him,
is that he kind of, he led Boston last year for the first,
I don't know, 21 miles or something like that.
Yeah, I think 21 miles, he led the race.
He's a rabbit, he loves to be super aggressive
and he's been sharing his workouts on Strava
and he's just an absolute maniac.
So everyone's like this guy's gonna crush it
based on what he was posting in this public forum.
His final long run leading into Boston was a 22 mile run
where he averaged five minute pace, so he's a beast.
And he sprinted like right off the start of Boston
and like led immediately and like really,
you know, aggressively kind of forced the lead pack
into you know, pace that was
probably uncomfortable for most.
So good for him, that's cool.
On the women's side--
Evans Chebet won for the men.
Right yeah, we should have noted
who actually won the race correctly.
Thank you, congrats to him.
Yes.
On the women's side, Olympic
and New York city marathon champion Peres Jepchirchir.
I hope I'm pronouncing that right, from Kenya won.
It was an epic final mile dual
with the half marathon world record holder,
Ababel Yeshaneh.
Oh, really?
I hope I'm pronouncing that as well from Ethiopia.
Peres ran 2:21:02 second fastest ever at Boston,
Yeshaneh ran 2:21:05, so just four seconds separating them.
Wow.
Their final mile was a 523 mile.
That's how fast these women were running.
That's amazing,
But just of kind of personal interest,
42 year old Edna Kiplagat got fourth running 2:21
destroying her own master's record.
42 years old, 2:21, that's unbelievable.
Insane.
Nell Rojas was the top American with a 2:25:57 performance
among the other kind of American women
who were getting a lot of attention
Stephanie Rothstein Bruce ran a 2:28,
Des Linden friend of the podcast.
Yep.
Was the third American. She ran 2:28.
Molly Seidel there was a lot of eyes on her
and she ended up dropping out.
Did she not even tow up?
No she towed up and I can't remember
at what point she dropped out.
I mean, again, I just glanced it,
results in Twitter quickly before we started recording.
So my take is half baked at this point.
Okay, cool.
I do know that Knox Robinson of course,
was there running 'cause he goes to every cool marathon,
Alexi Pappas, interestingly
ran as a guide to a blind athlete, Lisa Thompson.
Amazing.
So that's pretty cool.
And also this is kind of a story that's a bit aside
that I've been tracking and paying attention to.
Yes.
Ultra runner and amputee Jacky Hunt-Boersma
and I hope I'm pronouncing her last name correct.
Also ran Boston, it was the 91st consecutive marathon
that she's run she's on pace to set a new world record.
92 days into her goal to run 102 marathons in as many days.
Which is pretty cool.
Amazing.
So I think Boston was day 92?
Maybe it was day 92, I'm not sure.
Have you run Boston?
I have not.
How many marathons have you run?
None, really.
Oh, you haven't done an official marathon.
No, I did the long beach marathon,
like early in my ultra career and was humbled by that
and that's the only legitimate like marathon that.
Do you ever wanna run New York? I know you love New York.
Well, I did, I got a charity slot for New York this year.
I've gotta heal my back though,
'cause I'm not running at all right now,
but I'd love to be able to go
and participate in New York City Marathon in the fall,
we'll see.
Let's talk about St. George.
Let's do it, what about it?
I'm a little--
This is you, I threw the ball to you.
You're fumbling a little, little bit.
(Adam chuckles) Come on, this is your jam dude.
You've been following the Norwegians.
I have, I have.
I thought you were gonna go to St. George
and be boots on ground report.
I was supposed to go to St. George at one point,
but it's just not gonna happen for me, unfortunately,
but I'm really excited to see
what Kristian Blummenfelt can do,
and some of the other guys, Iden as well,
the Norwegians are ready to drop the hammer,
but it does seem like this race is
lost a little shine for me.
I was excited to see Lucy Charles-Barclay,
who won the half out there, the world championship.
And she was kind of like rounding in a form of field,
really good about her form.
I interviewed her for that same story I did on Kristian
and the Norwegians.
And so she felt, you know,
she was like really confident then,
and to have a fracture like that in the hip is unfortunate,
'cause it seems like that could take a little while.
And then San Bernardino,
who I also interviewed for that story,
who was very excited to see Ron, he also is--
Yeah, I heard that he's out, but why is he out?
What happened to him?
I didn't follow up on that, unfortunately, I'm sorry.
It's been very busy, I've been busy.
Adam.
I'm sorry.
You're working on a top secret project
that we'll be able to talk about soon but we can't--
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But I was, you know, he's 42 years old, so like you want,
but I think that having spoken to him
most likely he's gearing up his year.
You know, when you're, I think he,
everything orients for him to the North Star of Kona.
And so I know that he wants to do Kona
and I know he reveres Kona.
I know he wasn't really super stoked
with the idea of racing outside of Kona.
Right, so just for people that don't know,
this St George Ironman is taking place on May 7th
and it's been set up--
St. George, Utah.
As an Ironman world championship.
Right.
Because of COVID and all these other reasons.
Years it's last year--
Yeah, because they couldn't do it in,
they canceled it in Kona because they didn't feel like
if there had been an outbreak,
they would not have been able to handle it on that Island.
The island was like, basically saying,
we don't think you should do it and then that kind of stuff.
So this is last year's world championship,
but Kona will still is scheduled to take place
in October as usual.
Same, same.
Yeah, so it's still supposed to happen.
They're not divorcing from Kona by any means,
but they're interested in seeing Ironman as a brand
is interested in seeing what's going to transpire,
will this, like maybe people won't miss it.
Maybe they can travel every other year from and Kona
to cities around the world because Europe,
is kind of where the sport's happening now anyway.
You know, it's so funny cause when
it really started California like San Diego,
Santa Cruz, Mark Allen, Hawaii.
Like that was the epicenter of triathlon,
some Australians too but mostly it was like--
San Diego, North county, San Diego
it's really where the heartbeat of the whole thing.
And then Boulder came into it,
but it was always really North American focus.
And if you look at now the rankings and all the big athletes
it's European focus.
Yeah.
So to be able to take everyone,
I think this St George is setting them up to maybe see,
Hey, can we do it in Berlin? Can we do it?
Can we make it a more interesting thing for the sport?
Right.
Which I like that idea.
But then to come back every other year to Kona,
that's how it was kind of told to me.
I like that idea.
I think it is important to shake this up a little bit.
Yeah.
And try to make it more interesting.
There is something, you know,
epic about the legacy of Kona and Kona is what it is.
But frankly, you know,
it's not that interesting of a course,
like you're on the queen K going,
it's like I've spent a lot of time on the big island,
I've done a lot of riding on the queen K
after you've done it a couple times.
You're like, is there anywhere else to ride?
I think that the sport would benefit from mixing it up,
putting the world championship every other year
in a different setting with a different type of course
that would favor or disadvantage a different type of athlete
to really make it interesting.
Well that's, what's interesting about this course.
It's gonna be hillier, the cycling will be different.
The swimming, you're swimming in a lake versus the warm sea
May is not always hot in St. George,
so it'll be interesting to see.
And yeah, I agree with you like the cinematics
of imagine doing a race in, you know,
moving it around like Paris or Tokyo or whatever it is.
I think that there is an appeal there,
but we'll see how it goes.
But I am kind of bummed that,
that these two big stars are out.
You're always bummed when the two big stars are out,
but I think really it was always gonna come down.
Will the Norwegian experiment work, you know,
will they have a world Ironman champion?
Yeah, well, what's cool.
Is that there has been some shit talking going on.
If you wanna be on top of that,
the best follow on Twitter is Brad Culp,
who's a journalist in the triathlon space.
He's @ BBColp on Twitter and he tweeted the other day.
Triathlon needs rivalries and a few weeks ago, Joe Skipper,
who's a British pro, he's the UK Ironman champion
started talking a little bit of smack
about the Norwegians and you know,
don't believe the Norwegian hype train.
Yes, yeah.
You know?
And when we talk about the Norwegian,
what we're really talking about is Kristian Blummenfelt
and Gustav Iden.
Yeah.
Who are just crushing it right now.
And what's great is that there's this
training video on YouTube.
It's Gustav and Kristian on a track
with snow everywhere, throwing down like insane intervals.
In Sierra, Nevada Spain.
Yeah at altitude.
Yeah.
Right and they're just hauling.
And at about 10:40 or something into this video,
we'll share it for those on YouTube.
Kristian's got a little bit of a response.
(foot tapping)
Here he is.
He just dusted Gustav on this set, pulling away from him.
(indistinct chatter)
(both chuckle)
A little reverse psychology from the Norwegian hype train.
He looks great though.
The Norwegian hype train is looking good.
If I was a betting, man, I'm not betting against these guys.
I mean me neither.
I think he's already shown what he can do with the distance
Kristian and Gustav has too quite frankly,
he had a very fast race as well in Florida.
But the sort source of this is sorry to interrupt you.
The source of this is that, you know, look
Kristian is only, he did Cozumel
but he's not that experienced at Ironman.
Fair.
And you know, and--
(garbled speech)
He didn't have a great half in St. George, so we'll see.
Right we'll report back on that.
Yeah in the wake of May 7th,
we gotta talk about the Rollies.
The Rollie winners.
Do you remember a couple weeks ago
when we announced the nominees for the first annual Rollies?
Do I remember?
(Rich chuckles)
Yes, you don't remember.
I blank it out completely.
You know how I feel like people have received the Rollies.
These they're like my parents,
who by the way, are devout listeners now of yours.
Yeah, how did they feel about the Rollies?
My dad didn't really, wasn't really thrilled by them.
My mother really liked them
and I think that's kind of like, 50, 50, right?
It was an interesting response.
Like, yeah, I mean, a lot of people were like,
come on, man really, you're gonna waste my time with this?
My time is limited, but we introduce them saying like,
we're gonna now waste your time.
Yeah.
With a bunch of nonsense.
I mean, so tune out or enjoy.
I mean, it's entertainment.
It's your choice.
It's entertainment, right?
Yes, that's what we're doing.
Are we entertaining? I'm not sure.
We're somewhat.
Are we wasting your time? Probably.
We're infotainment.
Okay.
(garbled speech)
We're knee deep in this so we have to see it through.
Are you committed now though?
I'm committed.
So we're doing year two?
I'm committed, so for year two,
we also have to come up with a trophy.
I agree.
Yeah or trophies.
I think year two, we have special guests.
Yeah, I think that would be good.
We could have a lot of hype leading up to
who the nominees are gonna be.
We nominate, maybe we don't nominate on the air.
We dominate Roll On contact.
We don't nominate on the air,
we do extended Rollies for the winners.
We don't nominate on the air.
All right, well we gotta report back
on who the winners are and what's great
about this Google form, thank you to everybody who voted.
They come back at you responses like yeah,
we got like pie charts.
We got analytics on this whole thing, it's unbelievable.
So I don't wanna spend a ton of time on this
let's rifle through it.
Let's do it.
First category, best endurance performance
in an RRP supporting role who lobbied for this award
the hardest (Adam chuckles)
We all know who did it was Jason Camiolo.
He wanted it badly, he posted about it on social media.
He courted voters who knows what else he was doing.
Sending checks out, holding cocktail parties,
pulling a full Miramax, campaign's--
It's a scandal, it's a scandal.
He changes his avatar on Instagram to the Rollies symbol.
(chuckles) It worked.
This is how bad he wanted it.
It worked.
And you know what?
He shall be duly rewarded because he walked away
with 49.7% of the vote.
Wow.
To be the 2021, Victor,
in the category of best endurance performance
in an RRP supporting role, congratulations--
Congratulations.
Jason I wish we had a trophy for you.
It was actually Jason's idea that we get a trophy.
(Adam clapping)
I think he wanted it for himself.
We didn't get it together in time,
maybe we can do it (indistinct chatter)
I'd like to, just for the record,
say I voted for everyone but me.
Blake, I think I was one of your two votes.
Yeah, so Davy came in second with 22.6% of the vote.
Then we've got Adam.
Yeah.
You've got 22.3 (Adam chuckles)
Poor Blake, courteous Blake, gentleman Blake.
Yeah.
We'll have to work on that for next year.
I think Blake's impressive arc in
becoming a competitive athlete is not being duly.
I notice there there's an argument
that Blake is the best athlete.
I think that probably is true and the most diverse.
Yeah.
But we'll have to wait for another year.
But that doesn't matter.
But he pressure is on the staff (Adam chuckles)
to really up their game for the following year.
I see this category just getting more and more competitive.
I see my resume not changing at all.
(both chuckling)
Yeah, you could be the constant in this--
Yeah, I'll do the same three things every year.
All right, next category,
best endurance performance of the year by an RRP guest.
Yes.
The nominees were Hellah Sidibe, Robbie Balenger,
Courtney Dauwalter, Harvey Lewis, Leah Goldstein,
Iron Cowboy, Timothy Olsen, Lewis Pugh and Jason Caldwell
walking away with victory with 42.9% of the vote is
(table banging) drum roll.
We need sound effects, Jason, the Iron Cowboy
Yes, well deserved, congratulations James.
Moving on we have a lot of categories to get through here.
Yes.
Coolest person of 2021.
(Adam chuckles)
The nominees were Jonny Greenwood, Rafael Nadal
Bo Burnham, Nirmal Purja and Billie Eilish
and victorious with 28.7% of the vote this year
is one Billy Eilish.
It's not really fair that--
Headlining Coachella this past weekend, by the way,
I mean c'mmon.
I mean, Billy and Rafael are like two legit stars.
It's kinda not fair.
I feel like Johnny Greenwood didn't get enough love.
I know that was your, that was your guy 6.1%.
You got so little that there wasn't enough room
to actually write the percentage in his little slice box.
When did you have time to vote for 48 times Rich?
Yeah, I know right?
I didn't vote, you know, I stayed out of this.
Here you wanna handle this next one.
Best limited series about narcissistic self-mythologizing,
AKA scammers.
Scammer series or scounder television, I guess, right?
Yes, founder TV.
My favorite category, but I'm handing it over to you.
Okay, "Super Pumped", "WeCrashed",
"The Dropout", "Inventing Anna", "Bad Vegan"
And the winner is "Bad Vegan"
With 35.7% of the vote. Very interesting--
A little voter turn out on that one.
Not the best of that group,
but I guess given the subject matter
and interest of our particular audience,
it's not surprising.
But 'Inventing Anna" came in the second,
even though it's not that great of a show,
but the show is in popularity of the show.
That's so interesting.
And by the way, like--
"The Dropout" is the best, is the best of all of these.
But the hardest to watch.
In terms of quality.
Yes, hardest to watch.
Yeah, "Inventing Anna" is garbage.
Didn't I say that last time.
You did but--
I guess the audience disagrees.
How many people disagree with you.
I guess, but maybe the best at self mythologizing.
I don't know.
Anyway, all right, next category.
And I doubt it.
You've gotta keep this moving,
I'm a host these days, right?
Most RRP-LARP like film of 2021--
I'm keeping this moving forward.
"The Alpinist", "14 Peaks", "Don't Look Up"
"Roadrunner", "The Rescue" "Dopesick"
And the winner is.
With 31.8% of the votes, "14 peaks."
NIMS with a win, NIMS was nominated for two Rollies.
This one was a little closer with "Don't Look Up"
and "Dopesick", pretty close on the heels.
Yeah but I like that,
this is like one of those he's walking up
and you say NIMS was nominated for two Rollies this year
and he came home with one.
(chuckles) That's right.
Best book by an by an RRP guest in 2021,
another hotly contested competitive category.
We got "Bravey", "Think Again", "Why We Sleep"
"Dopamine Nation", "Regeneration", "Your Turn",
"The Awakened Brain", "Stolen Focus" and "Transcendence".
And the winner is Adam.
"Bravey" by Alexi Pappas.
Audience favorite, of course everybody loves Alexi.
(both clapping)
(garbled speech)
How comes everyone only claps for Jason, come on.
Yeah, I know, right.
It's Alexi.
We need like that little button drop
with the little applause, you know,
and also of the music that like cues us offstage,
the little Syphon, like little Diddy.
You need that too.
My favorite category is coming up.
It had a lot of responses.
Yeah, this was your I'll let you do this one
because this was your, this, you came up with this category.
Should we, we're gonna have to revamp these,
put a little more thought in the category next year.
I think five next year.
Yeah, I don't know what we're doing.
Okay, best RICH ROLL Nuevo obsession
Sprouting (both chuckling)
Weight Lifting, Decoding The Gurus
Ice Baths and Adam's Swim Mask,
Now this one, this must be very gratifying for you.
This is a landslide.
By a landslide, the biggest obsession
the most rewarded obsession of the audience
is Adam's Swim Mask.
Yes.
With an incredible 47.7% of the vote (both chuckle)
People can't get enough of the swim mask.
In fact, when I posted pictures of me, swimming in Florida,
people were outraged that I was not wearing the mask
that you gifted me.
(chuckles) I know, where was the mask?
Where is that mask?
Have I ever expressed any interest in wearing a swim mask
while I'm open water swimming? No, I have not.
It's your birthday gift.
That gift, I appreciate it, it was symbolic.
I could put it in like a loose sight case
and keep it in my office.
You should.
But I probably will never swim with it.
When you set up the Rich Roll museum.
Yeah.
Then I think that's where it belongs.
And I think given the way that the audience voted on this,
that will be the thing.
People will be most interested in seeing
of anything that we've ever done
in the history of Rich Roll.
It'll be great, it'll be like your mask
and then my mask, my mask will be all corroded and used.
Your mask will be pristine as if you could just
as never been used.
Right, but among the many other artifacts
signed books by luminaries or whatever, you know,
knickknacks that we've collected over the years
as a result of hosting this show.
Yeah.
The swim mask will be the thing.
The low tec swim mask.
That will go on the epitaph, you know, like of the show.
My swim mask won a Rollie.
I lost, but my swim mask won Rollie.
Right, what do we make of that? (Adam laughs)
Like that we could dissect that
into an interesting narrative.
Yes.
All right, next category, luckiest rocker of all time,
this is a garbage category (Adam laughs)
This is your idea, the nominees for Ringo Starr--
(garbled speech)
And again, Ringo Starr (both chuckle)
So, okay.
It's a repudiation.
When you...
An outright repudiation.
What's interesting is that
like the first mention of Ringo Starr got 41.4% vote.
Yeah, yeah.
The second mention of Ringo got 42.5%.
So Ringo walking away with a whopping 84%
of the vote extensively.
And once again, my George Harrison theory
does not hold water.
(Adam chuckles) Jason's clapping back there.
You should be rooting for the drummer my friends.
Let's put this in the rear view mirror.
All right.
The dystopia you would most wanna live in.
Yeah.
The nominees are, "Dune", "Station Eleven"
"Don't Look Up" and "Squid Game"
Interesting.
And the victory goes to "Dune"--
What do you think about that?
45.5% of the vote.
Would you rather live like with the giant worm
trying to swallow you whole all the time?
See, here's what I think people don't get
when they're voting for this.
They all imagine themselves as the hero in "Dune"
but they're not, most of us are not the hero.
We're the people--
You're like the the slave drone.
(laughs) You're the slave drone.
So you gotta think of yourself that way.
Driving the mining craft.
Yeah, yeah.
And being victimized by the Bene Gesserit.
Totally, you don't wanna be victimized
by the Bene Gesserit.
It's surprising that "Station 11"
only got 25.4% of the vote.
I chalk that up that people just haven't watched it yet,
because clearly that is the optimal dystopia
that you wanna live in.
No, like Chicago, you don't wanna live in that dystopia.
But if you survive it, then you're fine--
If you survive it.
And you can go like about your Merry way
as a Shakespearean actor.
Maybe I didn't say have quite a sunny reaction to "Dune"
but I think I--
But there is something communitarian about it.
Yeah.
And celebratory about trying to, you know,
find meaning in your life,
in this post virus world that we live in.
Agreed and they love Shakespeare.
They do and they seem to actually be enjoying themselves.
All right, (Adam chuckles)
as long as they're not getting killed.
Best performance by an ice-cream scooper in a leading role,
this is another scorney category.
(Adam chuckles) You know, I don't what I don't.
What do you can say about this? (chuckles)
Thank, you.
Two nominees, the Cold Stone Guy
or Adam at Ben & Jerry's.
Thank you folks.
Adam being crowned with his first Rollie victory.
Thank you, Adam Skolnick has been nominated for--
With 83% of the vote.
Free Rollies.
I mean, what are we even doing here?
Why are we wasting peoples time?
Thank you, thank you folks, thanks for tryna--
Best streaming series, the nominees
"White Lotus", "Station Eleven"
"The North Water" "Severance" and "Succession".
"Succession"...
Oh actually no, "White Lotus" winning with 35.1%.
Yes.
"Severance" which has taken my top spot
actually behind "Station 11."
I love "Station 11" but the "Severance"--
You love "Station 11 over "Severance"?
The severance season finale was unbelievable.
You haven't watched that, I know you kind of lost interest.
I heard, I heard I gotta go back in.
It's an extraordinary achievement that show.
You gotta check it out, shout out to Ben Stiller,
unbelievable work from him
and his team on that project.
Best filmed content period, series, film, whatever
Adam, you wanna list (garbled speech)
Bo Burnham for "Inside", Denis Villeneuve--
Villeneuve.
(Adam chuckles)
Villeneuve of "Dune", "The North Water"
"Severance", "Station Eleven"
and Rich's Stealth TikTok Account.
Why is that even a category?
That got 23.5 % (Adam chuckles)
more than my favorite show, "The North Water"
coming in with a dismal 6.7%.
But you just said it wasn't your favorite show,
your favorite show,
you just said two shows you liked better.
You're right, I've got lots of favorites.
"The North Water" though I mean, come on.
You know what Richard Skolnik.
That show is unbelievable.
Richards Skolnik is now in...
He hated the Rollies,
but he was very interested in your "North Water."
So is he watching it?
He's gonna watch it, yeah.
All right, good, hopefully--
See the Rollies do help.
But Bo Burnham walks away with a Rollie with 30.4%.
(Adam claps) He's a genius, let's give it up for him.
He is.
Honor Rollie, lifetime achievement award
for hardest working film professional.
There's no vote here Frank Grillo was the guy.
Honor Rollie.
I mean, congrats to Frank.
Last category most overrated, over-hyped film of 2021.
There was only one category here, "The Matrix Resurrections"
So it walked on with 100% of the vote as well (chuckles)
Well, you know, it didn't make a lot of sense
that the hero of the revolution
would then opt back into the matrix.
Right, let's just create a better matrix.
That's how that thing panned out.
Yeah.
Anyway all right.
Congrat.
We did it, so you can be mad if you're still with us,
but you know, we had to see it through.
We had to see it through and based on that,
I'm not sure year two is going to happen, but it could it.
Yeah, I know, right, it could, we'll see.
I'm sure we'll be on the receiving end
of some responses, both tepid and enthusiastic.
Oh, what do we wanna talk about next,
couple things I wanna mention the first is.
See what? Wait, see what happened there?
What?
I tried to then get into it, I'm trying to--
Okay go, yeah, yeah.
The timing.
I am throwing it to you, sorry.
Yes, no this is Bill Spindle--
I wanna be a generous co-host Adam
sorry, I interrupted you while I'm interrupting you again.
(Adam chuckles)
People get really mad that I interrupt you too much.
I think it's I interrupt you.
I do and I plead guilty to that.
Yeah I do too.
But also as a host, you're like,
I gotta move it forward.
Right.
What you're doing next.
The energy adventurers, what we're doing next
Bill Spindle substack your cousin.
My cousin.
Your cousin.
Couple years older than me.
Tell us about your cousin.
So Bill Spindle, he's been my cousin, my whole life.
(both chuckle)
He's a couple years older than me,
he is an amazing journalist.
He been a journalist, his whole adult life.
He was editor of the Daily at the University of Michigan.
And after that has just pursued this career,
I think he got his
graduate degree in journalism at Columbia.
He worked for the Wall Street Journal for 20 years.
He was the former south Asia bureau chief,
for the Wall Street Journal,
covering India, Pakistan, Nepal, Bhutan,
Bangladesh, Sri Lanka,
also the former middle east bureau chief.
He lived in Abu Dhabi for many years,
he was in New York city, living downtown
working for The Journal when 9/11 happened.
And he's just been covering climate change, energy
that you know, that sort of portion of the world
for a long time.
He's currently a council on Foreign Relations,
International Affairs living in India.
And he started this Substack
to kind of travel across India, cover climate change
and in a broader context,
the transformation of the global energy system.
And he's a wonderful writer
and he's sort of reporting boots on the ground
and it's pretty cool what he's done.
So in this world of subscriptions and so many Substacks,
I think he signal amidst the noise
and everybody should check it out.
So the link is Bill Spindle.substack.com
and I'll link that up in the show notes.
Yeah, I read great stuff on the Indian Railway System,
which was really cool.
It reads like a journalist that's been set free, you know,
like--
He doesn't have to, right?
Yeah, he--
He's not reporting to anyone.
No, but he's reporting is still good.
Like it's solid stuff,
but yet it has a voice and it has a you know,
we try to have a voice,
but usually it's kind of restrained in journalism,
but like his set free and he is trying to,
he has a point of view, that's really interesting.
And I mean, I think we always do, but like I said,
it's usually restrained,
this time it's kind of set free and I love it.
And I've always said many times the best, you know,
the best travelers are journalists
with their boots on the ground, in any country.
And they can teach us so much,
so I'm gonna be staying tuned in to Bill.
That's cool.
I could see you in another life with a Substack,
hoofing around the planet.
Is this my two weeks notice?
This is your multiverse.
Like if you were living in a parallel universe.
No, I could still--
You know what I mean? (Adam chuckles)
No, your job is secure here.
Okay.
What would we do without you?
You know, it's funny, I did that, you know,
I did it for nine months a year for Lonely Planet,
but Substacking--
But it was a pre-stack world.
It was pre Substacky, I don't think at that time,
I would've made a much of a living on Substacking
I do have an idea for a Substack,
but I gotta get some stuff done this year
and then we'll turn to it.
Right on.
Yeah.
All right, well one of the main things
I wanted to talk about today is this recent article
that Jonathan Haidt wrote for the Atlantic,
which has been up now for, I don't know, at least a week,
and is still the number one most, red story on the site?
It's entitled why the past 10 years of American life
have been uniquely stupid?
Yes.
So you wanna launch into this for us Adam.
So the background on the story is
he launches with the story of Babel,
the biblical story of the tower
of people who are technologically advanced
and they build this massive tower, but God curses them
to make sure they can't communicate
and it becomes this metaphor for social media
and what we've done
and how that miscommunication has imperiled groups
and institutions and the future of our country.
I think he talks about it as America,
but you know, this same problem is overseas.
Many places have these exact same problems,
it's not just here, Brazil has had it, Burma's had it,
Russia has it right now.
And so the idea is how do we get to this point
where people's idea of the truth are so completely divergent
and not just people left and right,
but within the right and within the left
and what's happening to keep dialogue from happening,
and make us dumber.
And he really hands it to Mark Zuckerberg, to be honest.
Yeah, for sure.
I mean, he talks about the kind of inflection points
along the timeline where this really
tipped into being a real problem,
where we went from this idea of social media
being the great uniter
and this modality that would facilitate unity
and communication into kind of the dystopic division
that we're seeing.
And the increasing acrimony between in groups, I suppose,
is a way of putting it.
And I think what's, you know, first of all,
it takes like an hour to read this article.
Yeah.
Like it's not a small thing.
Like it requires you to really kind of like wrestle with it
and grapple with it.
It's incredibly well done.
Yeah.
He walks you through kind of like how social media evolved
to the point where these algorithms,
you know, are what they are that are, you know,
increasingly creating these information silos, but--
Pre share, pre retweet, to post.
Exactly.
Like it's really the share button and the re share button.
What the retweet did, exactly.
Yeah, yeah.
And that's what brought the algorithm in
to reward those or to basically serve up
what people like to retweet and share the most.
Yeah.
But in addition to the use of Babel you know,
as a metaphor or as an analogy,
it's also a way of approaching this subject matter
through the lens of James Madison and the Federalist papers.
Yeah that was cool.
As well as de Tocqueville,
which I think is fantastic, right?
Yeah.
Like I'm trying to recollect my study of these individuals
as, you know, as a young college student,
but, you know, essentially like what Madison was saying,
which is true today is, you know,
you just can't quite trust the masses.
They get very emotional
They're factual.
Which is kind of an anti-democratic idea, right.
But what people often forget
is that we don't live in a pure democracy,
we live in a democratic Republic,
there are checks and balances on our democratic
purely democratic systems.
That favor kind of institutional stability.
And this is the whole idea with Madison's perspective
in the Federal's papers and Haidt makes the case
that idea, that warning, that Madison was,
you know, forecasting,
we're seeing in reality getting played out
in the democratic kind of forum of ideas
that social media avails itself.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You know, the idea that Madison is saying that
humans kind of tend towards fictionalization
and mutual animosity.
And so and he kind of called this
and the Zuckerberg point of it is
kind of like he paints Zuckerberg as this
obviously no one's saying he's not a very, very smart guy.
So he is this genius, but he's a very, very greedy,
very, very naive genius who kind of bumbed his way
into something that it has cost that he couldn't comprehend.
I mean, he you know,
like he was so taken with his invention
and the amount of power and money he was gonna make
that he didn't think of any negative cost.
And so this idea of lack of skepticism, which started there
has then past, I think he doesn't actually say this,
but I think this,
the fact that that founders of these platforms
lacked so much skepticism in what could go wrong
or just simply ignored it.
That lack of skepticism has been passed down to us now.
And so now you have people,
cause one of my favorite parts of this story
is he basically breaks down,
most of the people who are so political on these platforms
are a very small minority of people.
They tend to be wealthy white people
and they're either far right or far left.
Right.
And when you, one thing I notice,
when people who are super impassioned
on social media platforms, like to make points,
almost always, they're not skeptical of their own ideas.
Right, there's not a lot of self-awareness around.
Hence the dumbing.
On both sides.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So he talks about this hidden tribe study.
Yeah.
That was implement by this pro-democracy group
called More in Common that surveyed 8,000 Americans
in 2017 in 2018 and ultimately identified seven groups
that shared beliefs and behaviors.
And there's the one furthest to the right
that they call The Devoted Conservatives,
which comprised 6% of the US population
and the one that's furthest to the left
that they call The Progressive Activists
comprise 8% of the population.
So we're talking about 14% of the population
that really monopolizes public discourse on social media
because they're the loudest
and they're the ones that get the most retweets and shares,
which creates this, you know,
imperfect sense of what is actually transpiring
in households.
Yes, they're the bulk of the shares and--
And that they're both like white and rich on the polls.
(Adam chuckles)
Right? Yeah.
That's why we--
So we're being torn apart by a battle
between two subsets of the elite.
Right.
Even though we're shouting about, you know,
the elites in the context of all of that.
And what's funny, it's like how,
I think last time we were on the air, I even mentioned this.
It's like, I said jokingly that, you know,
if you're being ultra political, you're an asshole.
And so we're being torn apart by assholes.
Right (Adam laughs)
So you basically, that's the TDR, this whole thing, right?
Yes.
And yeah, yeah, so in other words,
like, you know, conservatives,
if you're within, you know, an aspect
of one of those in groups on both sides,
if you divert from that, let's say you divert
from the conservative perspective,
you're gonna get accused of being a traitor.
A rhino.
Yeah, if you take a position at odds
with the progressive side of it,
you're not gonna get called a trader,
you're gonna get called a racist, a transfor or Karen.
So on one side, it's the political candidates,
if you're a rhino, you lose, you have no chance,
but on the left, it is almost more insidious
because it can really harm you
in your daily life a lot more.
And I think he's a little bit breathless
and over dramatic about cancel culture.
I do think it's a problem, I think we've talked about it.
We've talked about this whole thing.
I think it stems from academic theories
that leaked into our newspapers and even kind of,
I think it's a problem,
I do think that there's too much academic thought
in our daily papers.
Yeah, sorry I was interrupting you again.
No.
The idea being that, that you know,
small percentage of people who are screaming
about that thing finds its way into these institutions,
into media and academia.
And even though it's such a small percentage of people
they're able to hold those institutions hostage.
Right.
Because the social ramifications of, you know,
the shouting that's going on about these issues,
it's the consequences are too dire.
So there's a retreat from really contending with the issues
and a kind of silencing of ideas that results
as a matter of course.
Right it's--
But you think that's overblown?
No, I think the way he frames it is a little overblown.
I don't think you know, I think one thing,
I think I have a quote here,
the punishment that feels right for such crime
is not execution, it is public shaming and social death.
I mean, I don't think every time something happens,
it gets to that level.
But I think there are examples of that level.
Sure, there's plenty of examples.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Of professors losing their jobs
and journalists getting fired and the like
there's quite a bit of it.
But it's more about like, okay so
maybe there's not hundreds of those.
Right.
But there's enough of them
and what is the chilling effect of that?
That's right, no a hundred percent.
You and almost every week we talk about stuff
we're not gonna talk about.
Right, well let's kind of contextualize this article
with the conversation we had on the last "Roll On"
about Leah Thomas.
Yeah.
So we tried to have a balanced nuance conversation
about a very difficult issue
and the challenge of trying to solve this problem
of serving both fairness and inclusion.
And I think we did as best as we could
with a problem that, you know, has yet to have a solution.
And I could tell you just publicly,
I was on the receiving end of a lot of vitriol
from both women on the one hand
and trans advocates on the other hand.
So women were angry that I didn't take
a harder core position or you
and I didn't take a hardcore position on fairness
and trans advocates were very angry
that we were even having this conversation
without doing it in the presence of a trans person.
Right.
Basically making the argument
that you shouldn't even be talking about this
unless you have a trans person with you, so--
Which I completely reject.
{Rich] I have a hard time with that.
I reject it completely.
Well, if you're gonna set up a condition
that you can't talk about out this issue,
unless you do A, B and C
like most people are just gonna say,
well, I'm just not gonna have the conversation.
Right.
We have to be able to talk about these things.
And yes, would that conversation have been more informed
had we had a trans person who's familiar
with this terrain with us?
Probably you could make the same argument
if we had a coach of a college,
you know, women's team--
Or just a women's scorer.
Whatever, you know what I mean?
Like of course,
any kind of like experience based perspective
on either side of that,
would've better informed the conversation.
But to say you have to that's the problem.
Right but the point being that like publicly,
I felt like it was hard, like I'm not courting controversy.
I tried to have that conversation,
I felt like it was important,
I think you and I agree on that.
Yeah.
Publicly, it felt like I'd failed everybody
and you know had done like a terrible job
of even trying to do this.
Privately, I got a lot of phone calls and text messages
and DMS from people thanking us
for having that conversation.
And those messages came from both sides of the camp
from women athletes, women, trans people, trans advocates,
trans parents and the like, so, you know,
but that's one example of the difference between,
you know, what is truly kind of like the larger,
quieter majority of people versus the very loud polarities.
Right, well, we were speaking
to that quiet majority, right.
Which is what I think people like about the "Roll On" stuff
is 'cause we tend to do that.
I mean, we might get onto the progressive side
more often than not, but often we,
I don't think we're that kind of religiously progressive.
And so we speak to this majority
and I think that's important.
I think the majority needs to speak up more
and support liberalism,
which is free thought and free debate and free speech.
And it's not in order to talk about this issue,
you have to have this in your background
or you have to, I mean, that's crazy.
And it doesn't..
I mean, yes you should have some,
you should be a serious person.
You shouldn't be talking about bullshit
you have no idea about.
Right.
But like if you study up, you can have a discussion
and doesn't matter your background.
So I think that that's important.
I also think that he talked about the fact that,
you know, the left is the one that controls the majority
of written media entertainment and all of this.
So there is this broader impact
of a quieter middle and a vocal left.
And you know, I thought about this
when I watched 'cause I had my niece stayed with us
and she wanted to watch the Grammys.
I don't typically watch the Grammys,
I've been like out of the mainstream music scene
for a long time.
Like I like what I like
and I never pay attention to Grammys
since I'm like in high school.
And, but I really enjoyed it.
And the difference between the Oscars and the Grammys
is like, it's almost like film people
seem to think that their job is education now.
And the Grammy people know it's entertainment
and like your job is to entertain
and so like there's this different,
like people have a different perspective.
That's why I have a problem with academic theory
in journalism.
It's like, yes, you can be in the op-ed section,
but academic theory should not impact news reporting.
But everything is op-ed now.
Right, there's so much, yeah.
But that's kind of my take
is that like people forget what their primary job is.
It's the stay in your lane idea.
We should focus on our primary job,
if you're yes, we need to have equal opportunity.
We need to have more opportunity for more people
who've been shut out of the system.
But that doesn't mean that your job isn't entertainment,
that's how I look at it.
Yeah back to the Substack issue though.
Yeah.
You're seeing this flight of journalists
from these institutions that have been kind of degraded
in terms of public trust.
But what's interesting is that those Substacks
tend to be pretty opinion for, you know, Centris,
like not Centris, like opinion first, right?
It's some version of activism journalism for the most part
in the most popular Substacks.
That's true.
And people who are distrustful of The Old Guard,
The New York Times, whatever,
seem to have the inability to lend that critical eye
to the opinion driven pieces of some of the big substackers.
Well, sure.
I mean, especially if we look at it on the left
because who invented opinion journalism, Rupert Murdoch.
So you're basically playing by that playbook
and it's a bullshit playbook.
And 'cause what opinion journalism does
is what a lot of people, I've seen it before
people make, they overstate their argument.
And when you overstate a winning argument or any argument,
but specifically a winning argument,
you make yourself look like an idiot
and it doesn't actually help the cause.
And so like we should all be more restrained,
we should all trending more to the middle,
we should all be thinking actually, you know what?
I don't know enough, I don't know shit really.
And that's what we were saying with the Leo Thomas stuff
was, you know look, this is what it's at stake,
we didn't make any judgements.
We just kind of presented all the thought
and feelings that were out there.
Yeah.
And did our best.
Well put, well put.
Yeah, but like the idea of back to the Oscars and Grammys
the Grammys was fun and the Oscars--
Who was performing, yeah.
The Oscars didn't get fun until the very end (chuckles)
The Oscars are well that got crazy.
Yeah.
Yeah, it is a different vibe between those two things.
You know what I'm saying?
Like Trevor Noah was up there having a great time,
everyone's having fun.
It's felt like a global thing, it felt like free.
It felt like art, it felt like entertainment.
Well, it's also much more diverse.
Yeah.
In terms of the artists.
You know, from country music to hip hop,
and the like, like you're casting a much wider net
in terms of the kind of people that are adoring the stage.
It felt like the silent majorities
preferred entertainment system
to the elite Ivory Tower weirdos.
(chuckles) Okay, there you go.
Yeah.
All right, speaking of elite Ivory Tower weirdos,
we had a whole category here of like cool stuff to share
and content that we're enjoying,
but we're at like an hour and 30 in.
Okay.
So maybe let's just save that--
Let's save it.
For next time, 'cause we did the Rollies already,
so we had our--
Yeah.
Diversion down entertainment alley
that I think is plenty for this episode
and maybe we'll revisit that next time.
So let's just go to,
we're gonna go to this listener question
and then after that, we're gonna go to
a quick zoom call with Chris Hauth.
Let's do it.
Sorry to interrupt the flow,
we'll be right back with more awesome.
But I wanna snag a moment to talk to you
about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know
actually already know how to eat better
and aspire to incorporate more whole plants,
more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans,
and legumes into their daily routine.
Sadly however, without the kitchen tools
and support very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly
and because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised,
I'm proud to say is The PlantPower Meal Planner,
our affordable all in one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious and easy prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team
of nutrition coaches seven days a week,
and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up, visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off in annual membership.
When you use the promo code RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life changing stuff people
for just a dollar 70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again that's meals.richroll.com,
promo code RRHEALTH for $10 off an annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
Just as a reminder, we entertain listener questions here,
if you want your question considered for Adam and I
to talk about on the show,
leave as a voicemail at 424-235-4626.
That's 424-235-4626.
Do it now.
Our voicemail standing by.
All right, here we go Jake, from your old neck of the woods,
Palo Alto.
Here we go.
Hi Rich and Adam, my name is Jake,
I'm calling from Palo Alto, California,
where I just relocated five months ago.
I left my hometown Ventura, California
and my dream job of four years
in order to be closer to my wife's family
and in hopes for the betterment of our marriage
and future of our five year old son.
I'm a vegan, 37 year old primary care doctor
and swim, bike or run for about an hour
every morning for my sanity.
Last month, my larger than life younger brother,
Steve was tragically killed at the age of 34
by a rogue power line that hit him on the head
while he was working on a ranch.
Six months ago, he married his high school sweetheart
after a 16 year courtship that included world travels
and great adventures.
Steve regularly swam in his Speedo in the San Francisco Bay.
Even in the winter, he surfed big waves,
snowboarded in the back country,
went off of cliffs and lived life to the fullest.
He was on top of his game with ambitious goals,
looking forward to starting a family,
expanding his agricultural tech company
and was in the process of buying
an avocado ranch in Carpinteria.
16 years ago, my older brother Dave
died at the age of 24 after heroic battle to leukemia.
He was diagnosed with leukemia at age six,
I was four and Steve was just one.
He was cured at 10, re diagnosed at 18,
cured at 21, re diagnosed at 22
and had a bone marrow transplant
and suffered the last year of his life on a ventilator
at Cedar Sinai Hospital in Los Angeles.
Not once giving up the fight.
These catastrophic losses have been heartbreaking
and trying to make sense of them is emotional torture.
My questions are,
do you believe everything in life happens for a reason?
And is there a point in trying to make sense
of this incomprehensible life and world we live in?
Or does this just lead to despair?
I respect you guys and appreciate all you do.
The RP has been an inspiration to me.
That's heavy Jake, it's a pretty heavy one.
My heart goes out to you.
This is heavy stuff, real life stuff.
And the questions that you were asking are philosophical
and you know, difficult to answer.
So I'm not sure that I can come up with anything
that's gonna be fully satisfying to you,
but I will say this.
To your question of whether we believe
or whether I believe everything happens for a reason.
I mean, I can't say that everything happens for a reason
in the universal sense of the word.
A hundred percent, no.
Yeah and of course, you know,
I concede in recognize, the difficulty
and the pain that you've experienced,
trying to reckon with this
and in this in endeavor to kind of
try to make sense of something
so seemingly senseless and tragic.
And so I think what I will say is that,
that setting aside, like,
is there a universal point to any of this
and focus on what I do know,
which is that I think you can find solace
and comfort in your own personal attempt
to find personal meaning in these events,
because these events, which are big, hard events,
present you with a choice.
On the one hand, you can either allow them to define you
in a self destructive way, the world sucks, nothing's good,
bad things happen to me,
but you know, I probably don't have to tell you
that this mindset is not gonna serve you well.
Or on the other hand, you can try to find some spark
in what has a occurred to ignite you
in a more positive direction?
When I look at or when I listen to you
talk about your brother Steve
being this incredible adventurer
and how he lived life to the fullest,
I can't help but think
perhaps that was a choice that he made
in response to your brother Dave and his early demise,
like looking at his life and realizing life's short.
And I've been gifted this life,
I'm gonna make the most out of it
and celebrating the fact that he lived his life in that way,
and that was a risky way to live.
And if you're gonna live life on the edge,
surfing big waves and doing the things that he did,
like shit happens, you know?
And it doesn't mean that the world is a terrible place.
I think he probably would say that he understood
that there was a risk in living his life that way.
But that was a choice that he made for himself.
It seems like the way it happened
was such a tragic accident.
Yeah, I mean, it was like freak out.
Like that's not how he died.
So it's like, I can see how that would be like,
wait a second and you, you do hear about that,
like these great people who have this amazing lives
and then they die doing something random,
like falling off the second story by accident.
Happens all the time you know.
Yeah.
But on that point of, you know,
making this other choice, like this can come in many forms,
like you could channel that energy
to raise awareness around leukemia,
or perhaps share transparently how you're surviving
this seemingly senseless passing of a loved one.
In other words, like can you take the unique experiences
of your life tragic, hard, and flip them to fuel a path
and service to others.
And I think we see this all the time,
like parents of kids that are killed in school shootings
become activists or they start nonprofits
to raise awareness around these issues
that have affected them so deeply and personally.
And I think that, you know, heartbreak and despair,
these emotions that you're experiencing
are totally, you know,
they're totally natural human responses
to what has occurred in your life
and I think you should feel all of that.
But the challenge for you at some point
after you've felt all of it is to process the events
in a healthy way so that they do don't fester
and become, you know,
the foundation for a lot of unhealthy responses.
So you gotta find a way to make peace with yourself
over what happened and transmute the events
into something positive for other people.
And I think when you direct that energy outward in service,
that will provide you with a path
that's lined with meaning, with purpose,
with direction, with fulfillment.
And it doesn't mean that you have to quit your job
or that this even needs to be your primary focus,
but devoting some part of your energy
or your intention to that, first through therapy
or some kind of modality to help you cope
and process what has happened to you,
which is an act of self love.
And then after that, through service,
which is an act of love for other people.
That was so beautiful Rich,
I can't add anything to that other than just say
you're a primary care physician as well.
So you're already living a very cool life of like,
you're kind of leaning towards service already.
You know, I think it's when you have a broken heart,
you feel, I think you can feel more
what people have gone through.
I think it allows you to be more empathetic
and I think that there's power in that
and not power like personal power,
but power in your ability to reach others
and to reach parts of yourself,
maybe that you didn't even know were there.
And I just wanna commend you
for living a cool life already
and for sharing this in this way.
And you know, life is a beautiful gift
and so we can't forget that,
no matter everything that happens,
we have to remember that life is a beautiful gift.
Whatever is happening out there, it's often tragic,
but it is a gift.
So we have to remember.
Yeah a hundred percent man, a hundred percent.
Well, good I think that's a good place to put a pin in it.
We're gonna turn our attention to
coaching call with Chris, but Adam, thank you.
Thank you.
Appreciate you.
I love you and I'll see you back here in two weeks.
I love you too, where's my Rollies.
Let's go party.
We gotta decide maybe we should outsource the,
or just you know, just put it out to the audience
to come up with designs for the Rollie trophy.
Yeah.
And see what we get.
I think that's a good idea.
I'm gonna go celebrate with fellow Rollie winner,
Jason Camiolo.
Yeah at the after party.
Where's the after party?
(both chuckle)
Yes behind the velvet row.
Yes, yes, of course.
Very exclusive and elite.
If he lost, he might've slapped us.
It would've been rough.
I'm so glad that the audience came through.
(chuckles) I'm glad too.
All right dude, see you back here in two weeks.
Like I said, I love you.
Thank you everybody for taking this journey with me
and "Roll On" we'll be back in two--
Two weeks?
Two weeks from now.
Yeah.
Yeah, right peace out.
But I guess the first thing I would ask you is, you know,
what is the typical experience with the athletes
that you're working with?
'Cause I'm sure a lot of them,
if not most of them have had COVID at some point,
so you have some data points on what's working,
what's not working, people who try to get back
into it too quickly, et cetera.
(chuckles) Yeah, I mean, that's the thing.
I think it's gone through every one of my athletes,
I can't really think of anybody who hasn't
besides myself (chuckles)
That's the crazy--
You still haven't had it, wow.
Not with four kids, that's even more surprising.
Right.
So and we have to test also going to different households
'cause it affects different households.
So if somebody's feeling under the weather
or something like that.
So anyway, but that being said,
your question is a legitimate one
because it's across the board different for every athlete.
But what I've found is really two camps
one and this is the larger group.
It takes longer than they thought to kick out of it.
They have this general sense of malaise
of just not being a hundred percent,
they feel good enough to train,
they feel good enough to do all the activities,
but they're just missing a gear or two
and they're surprised how long it takes.
And then from one day to the next,
the cloud lifts and they feel mostly back to normal.
And so they and those--
And in those cases, yeah in those cases
are you just asking people to train through it
and deal with it or is it better
to just take your foot off the gas completely or slightly?
Well, I think the first component there is
you can train or I let them train how they want to,
but recognize that they might not be at a hundred percent
and not be so hard on themselves because of it, right.
We're constantly evaluating how we're progressing.
And so it becomes this like,
ugh, I'm not progressing where I feel off
or I'm tired or I'm flat
or I didn't eat enough or something.
And I say, you know,
it might still just be this carrying on
for a longer period of time than you think.
So allow yourself to not necessarily once again,
train without intention,
but give yourself that little extra space
of forgiveness quite honestly.
But you don't think that the training itself
is ill advised or prolonging that recovery period.
I haven't seen it
because those have given more time off to,
or I've backed off the training completely
they're not necessarily getting healthier, quicker.
Interesting.
And so there's those who three, four days later
are basically back to normal and then maybe
another two, three days and then they're a hundred percent,
but then there's others three, four weeks
of just feeling just enough to notice that they're off,
that they just can't perform, let's say intervals
or strength work or paces that they were
before getting COVID.
And so it's just a close watching process for the athlete
and really providing the insight to me so that I can say,
all right, you know what?
We'll take out a few of these higher quality,
higher intensity workouts and just stay true
to the endurance or stay true to clean motions
or just good strength work.
Maybe we're not looking to top out the strength work,
but just staying connected to so that once you are healthy,
that you're ready to really hit that gear.
And that's the fun, right?
That you, as the athlete feel good about like, okay,
as soon as that fog lifts at least I'm ready
and I can have some really good training days.
Well, I feel pretty fortunate in that at least so far,
I don't feel that malaise or that general fatigue.
I thought like I might have to take a couple weeks off.
Like I had athletes pinging me, friends of mine,
and I know, you know,
because I know them and they're friends.
I know that they, you know,
they're not afraid to train hard.
Yeah.
And a couple of 'em were like, I took three weeks off,
like I just needed that.
But I felt pretty good pretty quickly,
like after four days I felt pretty much fine.
I was like, yeah, but I'm gonna be conservative,
I'm gonna sit this out.
And I think I took seven days off total,
but I felt ready to go and just very gradually
and gently got back into the pool, I didn't push anything.
Like I would go three or 4,000 yards,
but I didn't really do anything very hard
just to gauge it and see how I felt.
But today you gave me a 4,700 yard workout
and there was some hard efforts in there
and I felt pretty good, you know,
and I got through it and that's the most yardage
that I've done.
And I know there's a lot of a volume waiting for me,
but I'm feeling pretty grateful that I'm not in that camp
of feeling like I'm missing a step, maybe that'll change.
But right now that's kind of where I'm at.
But I did miss seven days on a pretty short time window,
I'm now eight weeks out of this swim.
So there's a lot of work that has to happen
and obviously, you know,
not everything has gone perfectly to plan
and I've got a lot more hiccups, you know, along the way,
over the course of the next eight weeks,
including this weekend where I'm gonna be driving up north
to your neck of the woods for an appointment for my back.
And I'm gonna miss a couple swim days in there as well,
'cause I'm doing the road trip with my kid
and I don't wanna be just training all the time.
Yeah, yeah.
Well, you know, there's pools up here too,
I could help you find it.
I know, that's true.
But like, I don't know, I'm like,
hey, hey Jaiya go sit in the corner while I go train.
Like I gotta balance that, you know,
it's supposed to be kind of like a father son road trip.
Yeah.
So with that being said, it's hard to know where you're at
with regards to the health,
because you might have felt pretty good today
because you also had a week lighter
leading up to it to really absorb the training
that you were doing prior and also increasing
sort of the build as you were going.
So it's hard to know that until we're a couple days
further down the road here,
at which point you're taking a couple days off.
So that's why we're taking the windows
and you're just a classic example of most,
any athlete that has a full-time (indistinct chatter)
as a family.
Like it's stressful for all of us.
And that's the whole challenge,
how to navigate these little windows when we can train
and using the time we have to maximize the fitness gains.
And so here we are eight weeks out to do 21,000 yards
in one fell swoop.
Right, so what am I looking at here?
How you know, is this volume gonna escalate?
Cause I'm itching, I'm always itching
at this phase to be doing more.
And you're always like pushing me to slow down a little bit,
but I've worked with you long enough to know
like those days are coming.
Yeah, well the beauty is we're starting
that sort of the bigger prep this week
with some longer sets,
I'm hopeful that we can get in two key workouts this week
and they include some long continuous swimming
and you're gonna curse me plenty then,
when you say I wanna do more,
and then I have two 1800 straight for you waiting
with four minutes rest.
(chuckles) And you're gonna do that in the pool
and be like really this my brain is going mush
back to our youth.
No, I love that stuff.
But the good thing is that with that, you know,
with our watches these days, we no longer have to count.
Remember back in the day, if we had to swim longer,
we didn't know if we missed the 50 or 100
or something.
Now we can just look at our watch, so lucky on that.
But that being said,
it's a great opportunity to swim 3,600 yards broken
and to do some fueling and hydrating halfway through
to see how you're doing with that.
And just think we wanna get better
at finding that all day swim day pace, right?
Swim pace, excuse me.
So that rhythm and that pacing
that you can just turn the brain off and just keep swimming.
And getting familiar with that,
so that now we have a baseline for going along,
in order to do that just a bit faster
and using that in our training in order to work around it,
you know, a few seconds faster than all base swim base,
a few seconds slower than all base swim base.
So we can start setting the intervals
and the work around that.
Right, a couple questions.
The first thing is, I got some good open water swims
when I was in Miami
and I have a lifetime of open water experience.
So I've never been uptight about making sure
that I'm in the ocean doing workouts,
'cause I'm comfortable enough
to know that like when I get there, it will be fine.
But do you think that it would be wise
to start incorporating some long course workouts in
because I'm swimming in a 25 yard pool
and I specifically go to this pool where they overheat it,
'cause it's more of like an older person therapy pool,
but that's perfect for the environment
that I'm gonna do this swim, it's gonna be really hot.
So I wanna acclimate to the heat and the overheating.
(clears throat) But I do think it, I would be well served
by getting some long course workouts in,
but I have to drive great distances like either to Pasadena
or way out to Simi valley to get access to a 50 meter pool.
Yeah, so that will take some planning.
And again, if we have to choose between
getting to a 50 meter pool
or getting in a longer workout in a 25 meter pool,
'cause you're using your training time to drive,
I'd rather not, right.
Because you're going to,
and I say that we're both nodding our heads
because I'm saying that because you already know,
okay, that what the benefits are a 50 meter
and you know how you'll feel getting into the open water
and lengthening out your stroke
and just finding that all day pace.
So is if that means we spend 45 more minutes in the pool
versus driving and you get in another 4000,
that's sort of the equation that we need to play
in these last eight weeks,
given that you have limited time every day anyway.
Right, I think that, that those moments,
I could pick those moments though,
where I do have more free time,
like on a weekend or whatever.
And you know,
you and I both know that no matter how fit you are
short course, when you get into a long course pool
and you throw down pretty hard,
like you're gonna be sore the next day.
Like it is different in a meaningful way.
And depressing too, 'cause you thought you were,
you were fit and next thing you know
you're like out of breath on a couple hundreds.
Long course don't lie.
Yeah, no that's a whole different
and it's a different swim sport.
I mean just knowing from being swimmers,
we know both know people who were world class
at short course meters or even yards, NCAA swimmers.
And then you put them in a 50 meter pool,
they never even qualified for, you know, the Olympics
let alone up to their potential than the world fastest times
they were doing in the NCAA swims.
So it's almost a different swim sport, so.
Right.
So when you're looking at how much work I've done
and how much work remains to be done,
are we talking survival here?
Like where you know, like obviously
I'm not gonna be tip top, but I would to be more fit
than just trying to get through it.
For sure, for sure.
With also knowing like I'm not gonna be able
to hammer the way that I would prefer
if I lived a different life.
Well, there's always that risk
where you just throw the dice out there.
(both chuckle)
See what happens.
Yeah.
You know, it's salt water you'll float long enough.
No but you had to look at it this way,
that you woke up today after a week sort of off,
and gently building your fitness back in
and quickly in three, four days or trying to,
and you did a quarter of the distance basically
this morning.
So if we needed to push ourselves,
could you have done a third or even up to half today
and back off the pace substantially,
but just continue to keep going.
Probably, you'd be sore tomorrow
or a little bit more fatigue, but you could.
So that's where we're moving to next,
where you do half the distance
and you feel like you did today
for a quarter of the distance.
That's our next check-in point.
Now hopefully that happens in the next two, three weeks.
We have five weeks to go to sort of
add that last little component,
are we gonna do the full distance? Of course not.
Are we gonna do three quarters of the distance
most likely not because we'll missed that window,
but when we go 12, 13,000 yards?
And you feel good about that? Yes.
Yeah, that seems totally doable.
And if I can throw down 12, 13,000
and not be completely wrecked,
that's the enough confidence for me.
Exactly that and fueling and hydrating during,
or the combination in swimming
because you sort of fuel with hydration.
That will sustain you an hour or three and so forth
so that you feel good versus getting fatigued.
And you think it's fitness
where it's actually running low on fuel.
That combined with as you're building the volume,
I think you will have plenty of confidence
going into 21,000 yards.
Yeah, the hydration and fueling piece is the next thing,
because I haven't done any experimentation with that.
I just go with water or nothing so far.
Yeah.
'Cause the workouts haven't been long enough
to justify it, but starting to play around with that
is something I'm eager to begin doing,
especially in the high temperature water where--
Perfect, yeah.
It's more meaningful (clears throat)
And what have you...
So obviously, this is a very personal thing,
but what have you determined in your experience
and you know, all the open water marathon stuff
that you've done, that seems to be a good workable equation.
Yeah, so for me,
it's first off in the warmer temperatures it's hydration.
Electrolyte hydration is so that at least that component
I'm staying topped off with regards to hydration
'cause we dehydrate in warm water dramatically.
Yeah.
And it's hard to recognize until it's too late
until we're completely sort of dehydrated
and it's affecting our performance.
The second part is that you will have that opportunity
this weekend just before I forget that
to do two 1800 with four minutes rest.
And so you can start laying out some different products,
whether that's shelves or chew,
personally, I like to chew
if I'm going to eat something solid,
I can get through them pretty quickly,
wash it down with water and keep swimming,
anything more substantial like a bar or anything like that.
I'm still chewing hard and working in that rest
or even swimming one handed backstroke
while we're continuing to swim and that's not ideal.
So therefore we have the chews, gels or bottles
with calories in 'em right.
And there's plenty of those,
by products out there that are really a good,
that have really advanced the technology
over the last few years,
there's a variety of products out there
like precision fuel and hydration, there is Martins.
So there are these bottles that have 200,
300 calories in 'em a lot of electrolytes, plenty of sodium.
And therefore you can also get your calories in
for what were looking to do.
We're not going that big in a deficit for your 21,000.
It's probably gonna be around five, six hours.
And so that's not gonna be something too dramatic
that with a good breakfast being topped off
and staying on top of it with liquid fuel,
you'll be pretty well versed in that by then.
Right on with the added complexity of salt water.
Exactly and so that's why you want cold fresh water
so that you can rinse out your mouth
so that you can get rid of that hunger debilitate
sensation in your mouth, that's salty water.
You don't wanna eat anything or drink anything.
You're just like.
Right.
You know?
So therefore we want to be able to test that
over the next few weeks.
Cool.
Yeah.
All right, so we'll check back in, in two weeks,
where would you like to see me then versus now?
Well, that's where we're are gonna start
adding those longer swims.
So in two weeks you're gonna have,
might be even up to 6,000, 7,000
where you feel pretty comfortable
and you feel like, you know what, that wasn't so bad,
like I got out and went on with the rest of my day.
Then we're starting to get good
that we can quickly extend to 10,000 or 11,000
because the beauty of six to seven to 8,000,
let's just say 65 to 8,000,
10,000, 11,000 is no difference.
It's just more time in the water,
but your arms and your body doesn't feel any different
and you're gonna laugh because it's really remarkable
how you feel just as fatigued that 7,200 as you do at 9,800,
you're just like, I spend more time in the water,
but I'm not necessarily more tired
and that's our next sort of, you know, threshold to cross.
All right, sounds good, man.
I appreciate all the Sage council.
Of course.
I'm actually really enjoying this.
It's nice to just kind of do one thing.
I can't tell you the last time I just swam
like pretty much every day
and didn't have to worry about all the other stuff,
because even during the most intense
kind of Ultra man training,
we were still only swimming like two or three days a week
at most, right?
Yeah.
So you never got that day in day out
cycle of swim training that compounds much more quickly
when versus when you're wedging it into, you know,
the cycling and the running.
Isn't the psyche sort of so happy
to be returning to this ritual, is it bizarre?
It's like going back into the womb.
Yes, I kept telling Emily the last year or two years,
or last year when I was getting ready
for the length of Tahoe, I was like,
I missed this just being able to swim forever
or turn on the gears automatically,
or just settling into a really smooth swim pace
the day in, day out, it just comes so naturally.
And it feels so good for us who are so used to
staring at a black line at the bottom of a pool.
And it is crazy for anybody who's watching or listening
because we have so robust background,
like even at 55, like I know that I'm still tapping into
what I started to build when I was 12, 14 years old.
Yeah and it's just going back in the mind
going, oh yeah, I remember this feeling
that I can just click 200 and 300 over and over again.
And I just, there it is, it's fine.
Right.
Cool, man, we're always appreciate it.
Well, glad to see you're healthy
and you're starting to look like a swimmer again.
I know my hairs gotten fried, you know,
it's like I wore a cap when I had long hair,
but I was like, my hair's short, I'm not wearing a cap.
And now like my hair is completely fritzed out
from the quarantine (both laugh)
But I'm kind like, yeah,
that's what you do when you're a swimmer.
I'm just embracing it.
Exactly, it's just that we didn't have beards back then
when we were.
I know, yeah let alone completely white beards.
(Chris laughs)
Well, it's good to see you're healthy
and I'm glad you're back
and I will dive into your training as we speak.
Sounds good, thanks my friend.
I'll talk to you soon.
All right, thanks.
Bye.
(bright music)